Right, now we're going to do a little bit more work setting up this behavior tree.
So I'm going to delete everything that I've created. Now I've also got a nice
clean starting point and I'm going to jump over to our blackboard.
Let's set up our different keys that we're going to need.
So you can see here on the top here we have a new key.
I'm going to do a drop down and the first one I'm going to search for is the vector.
Okay, that gives us a yellow key and I am going to name this location.
Okay, so this is just going to be a x, y and z float.
We're going to use to denote a location in space.
Okay, and one more that we're going to add in and that is going to be a object
and the object key we're going to type in and we're going to call this player.
Now the object itself is we're going to want to reduce the base class.
The reason is an object doesn't necessarily have a location in space.
So we're going to have trouble placing stuff into it.
So what I'm going to do is you can see that we have a base class here.
I'm going to select that. I'm going to change that to actor.
So that means we're not going to need to do a cast to get things like location.
So we're only going to be able to save references to things
which have a parent class somewhere of actor.
Okay, with that I'm going to save and jump back into our behavior tree.
So let's set up our first state.
So I'm going to drag off of the route and I'm going to select a selector.
So this is going to be our first state.
Then I'm going to drag off and I'm going to select a sequence.
And this sequence I am going to rename wonder around space in there as well.
So the first thing we're going to do is we're going to just get these characters to
wander around and this will be the default activity because it's on the left hand side here.
Now at the moment it's all right we've got a sort of flow nodes in here
but we're not actually asking it to do anything at all.
So what we're going to do in order to do that is we're going to
to get it to do something we need to add in tasks.
Now there are actually a whole load of pre-made tasks here
but we're going to create one from scratch.
So if we come up to the top here you can see we have an option for new task.
I'm going to do a drop down and I'm going to select BT task underscore blueprint base.
And I'm going to create a task I'm going to call it BT underscore find random location.
Okay so this is going to this is going to be a task where we're going to find a random location.
When we start off to make them wander about we want to find a random location and wander to it.
So once you've created your task you're going to get a screen that looks like this.
So we've got the blueprint functionality element here but we have no viewport
and that's because a task has no components has no visible aspects to it.
It's just a function just we're just going to be telling it sending it some instructions to do
something. Okay so one thing you might also have noticed is we have no red starting pin
and that's because we need to start by overriding one of the base functions.
So you can see here we have functions and there is six overrideable.
And we do a drop down we have a number of options you can see we have receive abort
so any code that is connected to this will be triggered if the task is aborted.
I'm not going to worry too much about that receive execute now this is what we are going
to use because this is the when the task is first run any of the code that is connected to that
is going to be run from the receive execute. Finally we have receive tick now what receive
tick will do is this will any of the functions that are any of the code that is connected to
this will run every frame whilst the task is running. Now you'll also have noticed that we've
got other options here so we've got the receiver bought AI we've got an equivalent with AI.
Let me show you all the difference is here if I go receive execute and receive execute AI
they're very similar except for we have some different input pins so for the receive execute
AI we are guessing the owner controller and the controlled pawn where from the receive execute
we're guessing a actor so it's just what output you want at this point. Now we are just
going to use for this example we're going to use the receive execute because we're going to
need to do a cast anyway so I'm going to delete the event receive execute AI and we're going to use
this one now we have the owned actor and all we're looking to do is get a random location
however I am going to want to pass out the data that we are calculating here and that's where
we are going to have to use a variable and a specific variable so if I push plus on the
variables and I am going to call this location and rather than a boolean what I'm looking for
is a blackboard key selector blackboard key selector here and I am going to add another
variable and this time I'm going to use it as a float I'm going to rename this and I'm going
to call this radius and each of these I am going to make instance editable so that we can see them
externally okay so I've created two variables location which is a blackboard key selector
and a radius now let's write some code so the first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
drag off the owned actor and I'm going to get actor location so this I'm just getting
finding out where the actor is and I'm going to drag off of this get random like reachable
point in get random reachable point in radius okay so that's the node that we want and what
this is going to do is this is going to just return a location which we will be able to walk to
now I'm going to drag in the radius if I place that over the radius I get this green tick
I drop that on it's going to use that as an input and that should be enough code that we've
got here now I'm going to do one more thing I'm going to drag in the location and get it
and I'm going to type set all that board value now this is interesting because in order for us
to pass data into the blackboard we are going to have to use we don't have to set a blackboard
key and in this case we're setting a location so we're going to set this blackboard value as
a vector so again a vector is just three floats denoting x y and z which can which can
be used to represent a location in the world so we're grabbing our vector I'm going to plug
that in and I'm going to connect up the random location now that's great so far this code is
good what this is going to do is it's going to find out where the actor is find the location
and then save it to a blackboard variant now there is one final thing that we we need to do
and I want to stress this because if you are making a task and you forget to do this
you're never going to leave that task you're never going to go back
to the behavior tree and move on to the next one and that is finish execute
so you have a finish execute here now this is where we go back and tell the code if it was a
success or a failure so we can either finish execute with success ticked on that means it's
a success or unticked and it's a failure and I'm going to connect up the output pin from the
get random reachable point in radius so that way we can succeed if we can find a location to go to
otherwise we're going to fail and this is important because this is going to denote how
we move through the behavior tree okay so that is the entire code that we need for this
I'm going to hit compile and save right now I am going to jump back to the behavior tree
and under our wonder about I'm going to drag out and I can I am going to type in
find random location and you can see here it's at the top here if you want to check if you
run it correctly there's a finished version but bt find random location now
if you see here by default what we have is two default values we have location and radius
and as you can see that's the same as our two variables which we have made instance editable
so our first thing that we're going to want to do is we're going to want to set the radius
because zero is not going to to fight go very far so let's change the radius to a thousand
and that allows us to change how the task functions the second thing is we are getting
a location and this gives us a drop down of what blackboard actor we want to save this to
now the self actor is not what we want to save this to we want to save this to
location so that has found a found a random area and it has saved it into the blackboard
the blackboard key has good location now if i drag off you can see that there are a whole
made a whole load of pre-made tasks and we're going to use the move to here and as the input
move to i am going to ask this to move to the location so again what we've done here
is we found a random location and then we've told it to move to it i'm also going to drag
off and then once we've hit the location i'm just going to ask it to wait and five seconds
is too long so i'm just going to make it wait for one second and i'm going to save that
now let's test so if i jump back into our behavior tree and i push play you can now see
that all of our npc's are finding a random location they're moving directly towards it and
then they are stopping for one second okay so we've successfully implemented a behavior tree
and now we can make it a little bit more complicated in the next video